he's the samurai warrior of Silicon
Valley
Larry's attitude is if you want to
compete against me then be prepared to
be crushed Larry Ellison started Oracle
software over 30 years ago and it has
made him the highest-paid executive over
the last decade with a total
compensation of one point eight four
billion dollars there was nobody better
than Larry at making a customer believe
that he could change that person's
business life with his product he sees
around the corner well before many of us
get to the end of the street he'll do
whatever it takes to win in the office
ASAP the german's software firm was
ordered to pay Oracle 1.3 billion
dollars or on the ocean there is
absolutely no doubt that he hates to
lose his company's technology has become
the backbone of the world's information
systems from government to online
commerce the brazen billionaire is an
ambitious provocateur with a singular
management style I have a theory that
Larry's succession plan for Oracle is he
is trying to figure out a way that when
he's six feet under in a grave he can
still run Oracle
loud and clear okay if you know anything
about Oracle's Larry Ellison it probably
goes something like this I've got a
Bugatti the fastest car this home cost
200 million dollars the fastest sailboat
that's everything go I'm addicted to
winning the more you win the more you
learn
he's a high-flying adrenaline junkie and
an unapologetic collector of expensive
toys and real estate he spent four
hundred million dollars to bring the
2010 America's Cup the oldest active
trophy in sports back to America for the
first time in 15 years but his success
comes from something far less flashy
some of the world's most essential
software tools you use every day but
probably don't realize that it's his
company making them work almost
everybody in the world uses Oracle they
just don't know it if you do any kind of
government transaction with almost any
government in the world any business
transaction with almost any internet
business in the world or any traditional
business if you have a credit card if
you have a cell phone if you have any of
the the modern things in life if you
live today I think you probably use
Oracle Larry Ellison arguably created
the most important computer software you
never heard of he was a man behind the
curtain for a tremendous change in the
way we all live Ellison remained behind
that curtain when we tried to reach him
to participate in this program
born in the Bronx in 1944 Ellison grew
up in Chicago when he was 12 his father
bluntly gave him some surprising news my
dad just said right before dinner oh by
the way you were adopted and we're
having meatloaf tonight it was so
shocking I just put it away and thought
about it for years without really you
know confronting all and realizing all
of the implications he dropped out of
college twice Ellison was a mediocre
student and disliked formal education
Mike Wilson is an editor for the st.
Petersburg Times and interviewed Ellison
extensively for his biography Larry was
not interested in following the rules at
school in the family or anywhere else
Larry needed to get out from underneath
the shadow of Lewis Ellison and prove to
his father that he could make something
of himself his flair for the fast lane
was obvious early Larry went out and
bought himself a turquoise blue
Thunderbird he was a stylish guy he
wanted to impress people he got in that
car and he drove it to California
Larry Ellison was a young man with a
great deal of potential his trip to
California it was critical to we would
become
Ellison settled in Berkeley and set out
to make a living writing code in 1973 he
worked at the computer electronics maker
am Dom there he met Stuart Fagan they've
remained friends for over 35 years I
went into my cubicle the first day I
worked there and across the hall were a
couple guys who never seemed to do any
work they just talked all the time and
one of them did nothing but talk about
himself how smart he was
how stupid everyone else was and how he
really ought to be running everything
and that was Larry Ellison Ellison was a
talented but impatient programmer
desperate to find something of his own
to control to say he he had the
attention span of a tumbleweed is to
overestimate it I would say more the
attention span of a lightning bolt but
his attention focused when he landed a
job at a company called Ampex Ampex was
struggling with a project funded by of
all places the information driven CIA
the project was codenamed Oracle the CIA
needed a system to store and retrieve
vast amounts of foreign intelligence
concerned with its various sensitive
operations and missions for Ellison it
was the job of a lifetime and would
plant the seeds for his future in the
1970s information storage meant putting
data on reel-to-reel tape which was just
too slow and inconsistent for the CIA
and too slow for Ellison he left Ampex
and later started his own company with
his friend and programming genius Bob
miner Bob and Larry were a perfect odd
couple for Silicon Valley
Bob had all of the engineering smarts
the technical ability Larry on the other
hand had the sales ability the visionary
ability the the ability to go to a
customer and explain here's how your
business can change with this original
handwritten sign and $1,200
they started software development
laboratories or SDL Ellison recruited
friends at oats and Stewart Fagan to
help program he did want me to join him
and he's gonna start some kind of
company and I thought that was the
stupidest idea I'd ever heard because
Larry wasn't famous for finishing things
I used to say he's a
total flaking he'll never amount to
anything and I was half right Alison's
new company needed a product and after
reading an obscure IBM research paper he
thought he had it a method of sorting
information that was vastly superior to
anything that had come before it was
called a relational database according
to Gary Blum who worked with Ellison for
14 years it was a complex name but a
simple idea relational Davis would you
know what did what is it it's a
collection of data and information
that's very simply put into a format
that makes it very easy to search and
find that information it's nothing more
complicated than that
IBM didn't see the potential of what
they had Ellison
did I said oh my god we can beat IBM to
markets because IBM doesn't believe in
their own idea Ellison believed and
asked programmer Bruce Scott to start
writing code for me it's just cool
technology and kind of fun but for Larry
you know he saw a company out of it he
saw a market out of it we weren't sure
Larry was right but B needed the jobs
and it was a struggle all the time Larry
was was under a lot of pressure to get
some money in somehow
you
in 1977 at age 34 Larry Ellison start-up
software company was busy creating a
smart database they thought would
revolutionize how companies retrieve
manage and analyze data three rooms and
a little Lobby area there were four of
us who are writing programs Larry was
mostly involved in finding customers and
that was a bizarre idea because we had
no software though all the things that
you would read in books of somebody
being a leader he wasn't but he was
tenacious he would never give up on
anything
Ellison chased and cajoled customers
becoming the company's chief evangelist
there was nobody better than Larry at
making a business person making a
customer believe that he could change
that person's business life with his
product
knowing they still needed a smarter
solution for the monumental task of
managing worldwide intelligence Ellison
sold his database to the CIA his first
customer he called the new software
Oracle version 2 there was no version 1
because everyone thought well no one
buys version 1 it's buggy so we started
with version 2 our version 2 is at least
as buggy as anyone's version 1 and I
described those early versions as the
roach motel of databases the data went
end but it didn't come out in 1982
Ellison also took the name Oracle for
his company he targeted government
agencies and major corporations in his
own unique way I remember him telling me
very distinctly one time Bruce we can't
be successful as we lie to customers for
some reason Larry told the Bank of
America I think he told us there were 15
of us when in fact there were five of us
I'm not sure why the Bank of America
would think differently of you if you're
5 or 15 but Larry had given them a
number which was a little larger than
reality
Allison also was sharpening a sales
philosophy rooted in a trip he had taken
to Japan in the early 1970s I was in
Japan and I was talking to a Japanese
business executive and he told me uh you
know that the problem with America is
that we just have no stomach for
competition in Japan we believe our
competitors are stealing the rice out of
the mouths of art you know of our
children in Japan we think anything less
than hundred percent market share is not
enough his take-no-prisoners approach
became known as the Oracle way the
Oracle way in the early to mid 80s was
just to win almost by any means
necessary
Larry's attitude as if you want to
compete against me then you better be
prepared to be crushed or don't compete
against me his product the Oracle
database took off like a jet fighter in
one of his ads and in 1986 Oracle went
public
his 39 percent stake in the company was
worth a stunning 93 million dollars the
IPO was a huge
it but was overshadowed the very next
day by Microsoft's public offering which
made Bill Gates steak worth a whopping
three hundred and fifty million dollars
in 1989 Ellison moved
Oracle to this mammoth campus in Redwood
Shores California which became known as
the Emerald City a reference to the
Wizard of Oz or as one newspaper
described it
Larry land and everyone knew who was the
wizard when I ordered a Ferrari 348 and
I was going to get the first 348 in
California
Larry ordered one from somewhere in the
East Coast and got it shipped in before
I got mine he didn't want to be the
second one he wanted me the first one
his obsession to be first took its toll
Oracle hit a wall the these aggressive
sales practices started to cause serious
problems
Oracle's aggressive sales practices in
the 80s turn the company into an
accountants nightmare the sales force
was so aggressive so willing to close a
deal and there were so few business
controls over the make up of those deals
then we started having the problem of we
certainly signed some bad contracts they
were also selling products that hadn't
yet been created Oracle was selling a
lot of futures so you're taking a lot of
money and a lot of revenue in for future
deliverables well then the question
comes when you finally have those
Liberals now who do you sell them to you
already sold it to everybody you sold it
to him three years before you had it it
didn't help the company's prospects that
their latest product was a dud Oracle
version six was riddled with bugs
customers were frustrated and sales
plummeted it's sometimes characterized
as the near-death experience of Oracle
in the early 90s and it was we weren't
cutting fat we're cutting into muscle
and you might even say we're in a couple
cases were kind of a couple limbs off
with Oracle's stock price and freefall
so was Ellison's personal fortune by
November 1st 1990 he had lost 790
million dollars his company was nearly a
billion dollar operation and it was
failing Larry was trying to achieve this
greatness he was building towards that
all the time and now he was in a sense
of laughingstock it was devastating for
him we're all a bunch of kids that grew
up with the business and we weren't kids
anymore and the business wasn't a little
business anymore was big business and we
had to replace virtually all of senior
management and it was a very painful
process he convinced well-known
management and sales consultant Ray
Layne to join the company and what he
brought was what I characterize as
operational discipline and a maturity
around this is how a big business runs
it was chaotic
it was painful nobody wanted to go
through that again
and so the culture was kind of reset but
the company's real Savior came in the
form of a new product
Zack Nelson was Oracle's youngest
marketing executive Oracle 7 was a
spectacular product the future was
incredibly bright and I think everybody
within Oracle at that time certainly
knew it in consents that it wasn't just
incrementally better his orders a
magnitude better Ellison's company had
dodged its near death experience in 1994
Oracle revenues passed the two billion
dollar mark and his stock as a result
was worth nearly 3 billion dollars for
Ellison that wasn't nearly enough to
become software sole heavyweight Ellison
knew he had to pick a fight with the
reigning champion Bill Gates he seemed
to be personally disappointed he wasn't
wealthier than Bill Gates
it's the scorecard and if you weren't
number one if you weren't richest you
weren't on the top you weren't the best
it was the scorecard and he was losing I
think that Larry thought he was in
tremendous competition with Bill Gates
and and maybe Gates didn't think so so
much Larry
wanted to be recognized as the greatest
innovator salesman evangelist in the
world of software and he had a steep
battle going up against the guy who
would put his software in every single
personal computer practically in the
world Ellison was fixated on gates he
would later admit publicly to hiring
private detectives to dig up dirt on him
Gates's new product Windows 95
had the entire tech world buzzing
including Ellison himself in this
appearance on the Charlie Rose show this
Windows 95 is an enormous ly complicated
piece of software and the idea of the
people can install this in their
households and manage these things their
household to me is hilarious and it's
time for something that's easier to
think this is clearly part of our
strategy to did thrown Microsoft but the
way you determine Microsoft is not
something that you throw darts at Bill
Gates and hate and envy Bill Gates you
have to think of think about products
and create products that are better than
their products that Microsoft is selling
Ellison made a move into the consumer
device market he called it the network
computer or NC he launched the network
computer with great fanfare the
computers we currently make personal
computers are rather expensive right
very very complex so we've introduced
this new class that computer for normal
human beings that very much pretty very
low cost very much weight now every
person can use a computer because you're
low cost and very easy to use you can
surf the net you can do email on and he
said and it could be $500 kind of an
Internet appliance so to speak no
different than your toaster I can
remember having a discussion with him
saying you know the Internet makes it
possible to imagine a world without
Microsoft's operating system on every
desktop and that was really you know the
birth of the MC Ellison went on a
campaign to promote the power of his new
baby on the web while mocking the
popular PC
I hate the PC with a passion put the
stuff on the net its bits don't put bits
in cardboard cardboard in trucks trucks
to stores meat yeah me go to the store
you know pick this stuff out it's insane
I love the internet but falling PC
prices meant the NC was destined to fail
I don't think there's anything wrong
with the idea actually just think was
premature five years later would have
won the world and the only difference is
all the PC manufacturers Dell HP
everybody else gateway what did they do
they create a $500 PC that surfs the web
really well and it does email really
well and that shut down Ellison's
venture into the consumer market his NC
was too far ahead of its time but his
vision of the internet was still right
on target
Oracle's database became the
underpinnings of all of these internet
services that we take for granted today
Expedia Amazon eBay go down the list of
applications all those are storing all
that information proving that
information delivering that information
doing those transactions through the
Oracle database what people thought
Larry was crazy now he's a genius and it
solved the biggest IT problem history
you
by mm Larry Ellison's company Oracle was
among the elite tech companies in the
world but internal struggles would soon
force out the company's president and
chief operating officer ray Lane who had
risen to second-in-command and heir
apparent
he described the culture at the company
he left wasn't good enough for a
Salesman to make their quota they had to
make 200 percent of their quota it was
you know the top 10 percent get rewarded
Millions
and everybody else you know falls by the
webs they're weak soldiers shoot him a
departing Lane said he didn't fit into
Oracle's system and that the only person
making decisions at Oracle is Larry lots
of people that transition them out of
Oracle got confused who was in charge
and that's a pretty volatile that's like
a galactic collision yeah where two
stars hit and it's a pretty violent
explosion Oracle the company was on a
roll but was lagging behind in one key
area we're still fighting to be relevant
in the applications world where the
number two application provider in the
world and we're number two an ERP behind
sa P boy this number two is getting old
number two number on we're number two
we're number two in CRM behind Siebel
but we're growing faster than sa P and
we're growing faster than Siebel and
were determined to become number one in
applications as like we're number one in
database to get to number one
Ellison needed to do something his
company had long avoided buying new
technology through acquisitions when he
came to that conclusion
he opened his wallet and bet bitten far
bigger than anyone else did and in fact
he did it far faster than anyone else
did Ellison wanted to bundle new
application software with Oracle's
successful product line in 2003 he
targeted the company PeopleSoft and
hostile takeover attempt the Department
of Justice sued Oracle on antitrust
grounds charging the takeover would
empower the company to illegally raise
rates and impair innovation after a year
to half long battle the court sided with
Oracle Ellison finally acquired
PeopleSoft
for ten point three billion dollars it's
very rare that someone gets sued by the
government and they actually win you
know I mean it's just another testament
to this guy's tenacity most guys would
have maybe walked away from that instead
Ellison stepped it up over the next five
years he would spend close to thirty
four billion dollars acquiring fifty-two
companies Heather Bellini is senior
managing director of the technology
research team at International Strategy
and investment group she is covered
Oracle since 2003 she started looking
out and seeing how the landscape was was
changing and how the carnage that was
done to some of his competitors was
going to give him an opportunity to go
make some acquisitions and buy some
technology where he was behind and he
really was the one that started the
whole ma trend within the technology
industry
ellison's appetite for acquisitions
accelerated in 2009 with his seven point
four billion dollar trophy purchase of
the prominent hardware company Sun
Microsystems
but in 2010 his eyes were on another
trophy a decade-long four hundred
million dollar obsession BMW Oracle
Racing was launched in 2004 Ellison's
run at the America's Cup it may be the
oldest active prize in international
sport but what Ellison created was
entirely new the boat is a trimaran it
often appears to be nearly flying with
only one of its three holes actually in
contact with the water the oceans have
never seen anything like it there is
absolutely no doubt that he hates to
lose there's no doubt about at all grant
Dalton has competed against Ellison on
the America's Cup circuit my
recollection and racing against time and
we will race against him in the future
this is a man that's very determined to
work on Valentine's Day 2010 Ellison
brought the America's Cup back to the
United States for the first time in 15
years he celebrated with his now ex-wife
romance novelist Melanie craft it was
his fourth marriage
the old samurai warrior reemerged when
his friend mark heard resigned as CEO
and hewlett-packard amid allegations of
sexual harassment and expense account
irregularities Ellison was outraged he
attacks the HP Board of Directors he
said quote HP board just made the worst
personnel decision since the idiot on
the Apple board fired Steve Jobs many
years ago exactly one month later
Allison stunned the business world when
he turned around and hired the ousted
executive the Silicon Valley soap opera
continued when HP named Leo Apotheker as
its chief executive his former company s
AP is Oracle's biggest rival in business
software s ap and Oracle had been locked
in a nasty three-year copyright
infringement case that ended in November
2010 s ap the German software firm was
ordered to pay Oracle 1.3 billion
dollars it was the biggest settlement
ever for software piracy Larry Ellison's
brawl had drawn new blood on the
information technology battlefield and
as always he is more determined than
ever to win Larry Ellison is pretty
similar to the New York Yankees they're
the team you love to hate and as a
competitor to Larry Ellison I'm sure
that he's the person that people love to
hate just given how successful he's been
well those visionaries you think are
sort of just talking off their hat and
saying oh this is how the world can be
you know Larry sees how the world can be
and then he actually tries to make it
that
he started with a $1,200 stake in a
little company and by sheer force of
will and persuasion he built it into one
of the giant software companies of the
world